well um you're getting my first question
so I was thinking about uh Patricia
arette because of our Gonzo girl
interview and also the multitude of
incredible directors you've worked with
do you notice any shared traits among
the directing great but then also can
you pinpoint something about your ghost
that makes him stand out oh yes um the
broad stroke about all the greats are
you know they've got something that they
see that nobody else sees they have a
personal Vision that's what you look for
you look for people that really see
something and you try to see it with
them and you try to embody it that's the
game and that's why you seek out strong
directors that aren't just crafting
something together they need to see this
thing and they need to realize it um
yorgos he's a uh he's truly a polymath
in the sense of he's a very cultured guy
he knows many things
about uh many different things he knows
architecture he knows music he knows
dance so when he creates this world the
way he works with all the elements of
production and let's face it it's a
pretty dense and pretty exotic world
it's so beautiful and he gives you such
a specific world that when you get there
you know how to enter it beautiful
script beautiful costumes beautiful
music the music's not there when you're
there but you get the idea uh that's
that's what you look for you get a lot
of help and a lot of fun things to do as
an actor when you've got a director like
that all those things are beautiful and
then beautiful performances on top of
that Mark with your character he goes
through quite the evolution throughout
the film so is there a particular scene
that put him into Focus for you most a
scene that you carried with you and
found influencing all the other scenes
you did oh man um I mean they all sort
of ADD up in a certain way
um the dancing uh the dancing has so
much in it and it you know it was
something that we worked on we
collaborated on you know Emma and I were
it was it was choreographed but then we
also threw some of that out and we're
just playing and finding some of that
and it just has so it has that dance is
their whole relationship in a way and it
was so much fun and it was so free and
and and we still had we were still
performing acting our characters in it
and then the fight that ensues that that
was all yeah that was a really fun and
and informative uh sequence I'm so
jealous if you're jealous I I'm
happy because I've been jealous of you
the whole time I'm gonna end with a with
a big personal career career question
for you both inspired by Bella's journey
in the movie because I love how Fully
Alive she is because she doesn't see
anything wrong in a number of things
that Society deems wrong so what is
something you thought was wrong When
approaching your work as an actor
because of what you heard elsewhere but
then you came to learn it wasn't wrong
and that realization let you be more
free with your work wow excellent
question but I'm not sure I can scramble
and answer because it's enough it's
every time you do something I think I
think the lesson that you learn is you
got to reinvent your process every time
because the demands and what you're
encountering what your function is and
what the challenges are are always
different so you're constantly facing
these things that you thought were given
they were taken as given truths and
you're finding out it's not true and
that's always when you have these leaps
uh where you really are able to get into
another way of being so you look for
those you look for those places where
you're locked you try to unlock them so
you can let everything flow so I didn't
really give you an answer but uh it's a
good question a good it's a good
question um all right yeah he's got to
go no no give unless they kick me out
you're allowed to answer yeah a few
minutes um this I mean this part was one
of those things I I was scared of it I
uh I I felt limited I I you know I felt
like it was wrong for me to do it in a
weird way just because of expectations
people might have on me as a performer
as an actor as a and and I just uh and I
I did it and I and it was so right and I
at the time I thought maybe this is so
wrong and so it's piggybacking on what
Willam says is is uh you know the
creative act and just pushing out
against your own um limitations that you
set on yourself that Society sets on you
those limitations that you set on
yourself are usually those of society
and the more you can challenge that the
more the bigger you get the the more
expansive you are I think the more
interesting you are the more lived you
are
yeah